hello everyone
my name is slava and today i want to
talk about the concept of lake house
which is a
data platform
and i want to talk about how it can be
built on top of such frameworks as
delta lake uh by spark and trino
um so first of all let me briefly
introduce myself i'm a senior data
engineer at the company datadog
i have around 10 years of professional
experience in pack and data engineering
i hold master's degree in computer
science from the university of born in
germany
and i hold specialist degree in applied
mathematics and computer science in
tomsk state university in russia
and my main interests are in the areas
of data platforms that architectures
distributed data processing
distributed storage systems and cloud
services
so the company i represent is data dock
as i said
it is essentially a monitoring and
security platform
that helps companies improve their
observability and security of the
infrastructure and applications
so briefly what i'm going to talk about
today so first of all i want to
introduce the concepts of data warehouse
and data lake
uh then i want to show you
the limitations of them and uh what
a perfect data platform could look like
and what we would expect from it uh then
i will talk about three frameworks that
can be used to build such a platform and
essentially apache spark data lake table
format and apache trino
and in the end i will present the lake
house platform how
uh how i can see it could be built
so let's jump in and essentially first
topic is data warehouse and data lake
so what is data warehouse every company
has
operational data operational databases
which
store data that can be useful for
business decisions essentially and
traditionally what would be done is
this data would be ingested into one
central analytical database
that can be then where then analysts
could query the data create reports and
dashboards on on top of it
and such system usually would have this
set of properties
so it holds structured or tabular data
it provides you sql
interface
ingestion of the data is usually in a
batch mode so something like once a day
schema would be usually on right which
means it has to be
provided and created in advance
usually such systems have acid
guarantees which means you have some
type of transactions which have
isolation and atomicity
the the standard use cases as i said are
analytics and reporting
it's not really well suited for machine
learning and stream processing use cases
just because it's hard to extract big
volumes of data out of it to do the
training for example or for stream
processing there's just usually no such
feature that would provide you with
streaming
storage and compute traditionally were
coupled so nowadays there are some of
the systems data warehouse system that
actually have them decoupled but
traditionally most of the system they
had search and compute coupled
and
because of this reason
it's it's hard to
scale it out
it's difficult and expensive so
um yeah so to overcome
some of these limitations companies
started creating data lakes and uh
usually that would be
an inbuilt or in-house
system that
yeah like a team or several teams of
engineers would basically build it from
from scratch
and usually use cloud
storage to put data into
and so the idea would be to actually
provide
or enable those use cases that were not
possible by by the data warehouse system
and so here the main characteristics
usually would be that
we can now store also semi-structured
and unstructured data not only
structured tabular
we are able to run non-skill based
workloads by using different frameworks
such as apache spark or pandas for
example
patch ingestion is of course available
so some limited
streaming ingestion transformation
is available but yeah rather limited i
would say
mostly it would be schema and read
because so now we have an opportunity to
ingest a lot of data into it in
different unstructured semi-structured
formats and so hence uh the reader would
usually have to make sense of this data
and figure out schema
usually would not have any acer
guarantees and updates and deletes would
be either very limited or non-existent
at all
but now you can actually run training on
this data you can read big volumes of
data from the object storage
training models
yeah and essentially have machine
learning
most of the time it will be based on
many open source frameworks and formats
again such as for example apache spark
or parquet file format
storage and compute are now decoupled
which is nice
we can scale them out separately
which which becomes now much easier and
of course here the cloud
service would be the the foundation for
this
so now when we have these two systems so
of course
new issues
come out and essentially
the the main one is that okay with two
systems somehow you have to keep them in
sync so you have new conventions or new
features
one
starts providing the other one has also
to to adjust and somehow you need to
synchronize this and usually of course
you would have different teams of
engineers working on them
this can be difficult
um in case of ingestion from the data
lake into data warehouse the data in
that warehouse can become stale just
because there is maybe an incident or
just a delay in the processing and you
can go out of sync also in the data in
the sense of the data
um different use cases as we
saw they have to work with one or the
other platform so for some for analytics
you would use mostly that warehouse and
for machine learning you would use data
lake and so different teams different uh
practitioners they have to work with
different systems and operate different
systems so can be also difficult
and yeah we kind of duplicate the cost
of storage and also compute
um okay so we have
achieved a lot with this but then we
also have seen that there are many
limitations so
what we would expect from a sort of
perfect data platform that would to
solve everything
um so from the picture you see now that
we can store all the types of data and
we have all the different use cases
covered and there is like a one central
uh data platform
and basically
referring again to all those
characteristics that data warehouse and
data lake systems had
we want
sort of advantages from both of them
structured semi-structured unstructured
data sql non-scale workloads
patch and streaming modes of ingestion
and transformation
metadata schema and write schema
evolution asic guarantees
so that we can also update and delete
data
analytics report and data science
machine learning all the different use
cases covered
ideally based on open source
and also of course decoupled search and
compute
yeah so there will be our north star so
that's what we will be working towards
through through the rest of the
presentation
so
basically we need three components to to
build such a data platform so we need a
processing framework we need a storage
system or storage framework and somehow
we need then
to serve this data to access it in a
convenient way
all right let's start with the first one
data processing framework
the requirements particularly for for
the data processing framework would be
it has to be scalable and general
purpose so it has to be able to cover
uh all the different use cases uh
has to have
connectors to all the different data
sources and file formats
it needs to have batch and streaming
modes of processing that's quite
critical
and yeah ideally open source would be
much better because then there is a big
community there are always new features
and you can also even influence it if
you see different
features are more important for your use
cases
and then there is apache spark that
as we will see
can serve these purposes quite well
maybe can you raise hands those of you
have who have worked actually with
apache spark has some idea
okay around the half i think of the
audience all right so
basically apache spark is an engine for
large scale data processing supports
general execution graphs unlike for
example hadoop map reduce which is very
limited to sort of one one phase of
processing which you have them to chain
in this case you can actually build
really
arbitrary
processing yeah anything
it provides high-level apis in many
languages as such as python java scala r
and also spark sql
and it has inbuilt libraries for
machine learning for graph processing
and for stream processing
um a little bit about its architecture
so it's pretty common
one driver multiple executors
architecture so essentially that's where
the distributed part can be seen and so
your code would usually be
in the driver process and that's what
actually your in case you're using pi
spark in python you that that will be
your code that you're actually writing
and looking at trying to debug and then
whenever you do the actual processing of
the data which then will happen in
multiple executors on multiple machines
uh that will be distributed to those
machines uh by the yeah by the driver
using the
the resource manager which usually would
be like yarn or kubernetes for example
um and yeah spark has
all the different connectors for
different systems of course different
databases mysql postgres
mongodb cassandra edge base
but also
such system as kafka for example which
can be very useful for stream processing
and the delta lag format
together with also all the other
different file formats uh and this will
be very useful in our particular case
okay let's now have a look at the
traditional typical by spark patch job
that just reads data from somewhere
makes simple transformations and writes
the results
so this is the way how we would read the
data in that is in json format somewhere
on the in object storage maybe
then we would do different
transformations and you can see this
looks sort of similar to sql in general
like we use keywords or functions such
as select where group by
uh aggregate functions like sum and max
and and then we can chain those the way
we want to express our maybe business
uh level uh yeah transformations and in
the end when we are done with the logic
we want to write it somewhere to another
location maybe in this case in parque
format
and partition by certain columns so then
it's easier to access later and you can
see this is a very simple piece of code
which
represents a
distributed processing job
which shows that
you can use different types of data in
the source and the destination and you
can do arbitrary transformations
then for the streaming it's very similar
it's
almost the same maybe the only
difference is that you do spark that
read stream instead of as part of treat
as the last example and then in this
example we read from a kafka topic we
specify what is the topic name and where
is it located then we again we do
transformations and we write it to
another kafka topic for example
and essentially this job now will
unlike the
batch job which runs just one time and
finishes as soon as it is done this job
will be running forever until we stop it
or until it fails
all right so we we've covered the the
processing framework
uh that's good now let's look at the
storage so storage is not less important
and what we what we want our need from
the storage system it has to be of
course also scalable and general purpose
storage format so like support all the
different types
of data
it has to have schema so like if we
think about maybe json or csv like it's
same structure that has kind of
uh
implicit schema but really there is no
well-defined schema that is enforced
and we want to have it it has to have ac
transactions this is very important when
we have multiple
writers and readers and we don't want
the readers to see partial data or
corrupted data if the writer failed for
example
so it also has to support batch and
streaming modes of writing and reading
and
ideally it has to be open source so that
again
there is a community
and it's like live framework
and there is such a framework which is
called delta lake which originated from
the company called databricks
and it first was proprietary format but
then they open sourced it
and
by now
it has become pretty mature
so data lake is an open source storage
framework that is
has scalable data and metadata as well
it supports ac transactions
it supports schema enforcement and
evolution
it supports updates and deletes and this
is pretty crucial as well especially for
such use cases as for example data
privacy laws when you have to delete
data from your
data lake or lake house
to be compliant
and it supports patching streaming modes
of reading and writing which again is
super critical
it has more features such as for example
time travel which means that
you write more data and at some point
like later you can actually look at the
state of of this data set as it was in
certain time in the past and maybe you
can actually run queries to compare the
state one year ago and today and run
some analysis on top of that
um
most of engines
such as for example again apache spark
or trina or hive
they have by now connectors for delta
lake
uh yeah and so now let's look briefly
into internals so that
um yeah we get some idea how it actually
works why how and why it provides those
features so if we if we look
sort of physically what it is on in
object storage like what are files
so parquet files would represent or
contain the actual data
and then there would be a delta log
folder which would contain the metadata
or
it's also called transaction log
essentially it's a history of all the
changes
that happen to the data yeah and let's
just look at an example so
first let's look at a traditional
parquet data set so we have some
location where we have two parquet files
and so this we would call arcade dataset
but then uh
with the delta lake uh we would have
also a folder delta log where we would
have a list of json files and every json
file would represent one commit
it could be uh
an insertion an update a deletion uh or
even a change of the of the table like
uh if you think about sql like alter
table command
uh and it would actually say okay
this file was added to the to the data
and maybe this other file was removed
and by reading this metadata these json
files the reader can infer what is the
current state of the data like table
what are the actual parquet files that
it needs to read so it wouldn't as is so
with with the original parque data set
it would actually need to list the the
folder and just plainly find out what
are the files to read in this case with
the delta lake it will actually get this
information from the metadata
and that's that's also in terms of the
optimization it's very good because the
listing operation is usually quite
expensive in the object storage
and you can read about this much more uh
in this blog article from databricks in
the
bottom okay so now when we know a little
bit how it works uh in terms of your
like file structure let's look how how
it provides those features uh like for
example acer guarantees
so let's imagine so for atomicity and
isolation let's imagine that we have a
writer it writes in a pen mode to a
delta like table by this path output
data table and then we have a reader
that
reads from the same location
and here we can have uh the this kind of
race condition situation
when like depending on who starts or
finishes first can be different outcome
um and yeah i guess here it will be all
a little bit in the wrong place um so
let me explain it to you basically what
happens is that
if the reading starts before writing
completes so the reader has to see the
previous state and like in black
i i put the the state of the table sort
of the previous state before the write
completes and so the reader will only
see those files in black because that is
what is written in the metadata
but if
the reading starts after the writing
completes
the reader will see already the new
commit file and it will read that there
are more files and it will read all of
them
and that's essentially how delta lake
format provides
atomistic isolation and
it doesn't allow you to read the
inconsistent state of the table the the
intermediate state of the table
then for consistency part from the acid
so let's imagine we have a data frame we
write it to a data table maybe this is
just the time we create the data table
from scratch and you can see that we
have two columns co1 and co2 and the
types are long and string
and now let's imagine we want to write
another piece of data into this table
but in this case we created uh our data
frame with the two columns of types long
and long so you can see that schemas are
inconsistent
and if we try to do this we get an
exception which says fail to merge
incompatible data type string type and
long type
and so this is called schema enforcement
and essentially we just cannot cannot do
this we cannot break the the consistency
or maybe better word with the integrity
of the table there are also other types
of guarantees such as for example we can
make a column to be not null or we can
put a arbitrary check with a logical
condition and then if this logical
condition for a value doesn't pass then
again we would just get an exception
for durability obviously it just comes
from the guarantees of the object
storage so if
files are written to the object storage
all those
nines from the guarantees that it
provides they basically give us the
durability
so now let's have a look at how it can
provide streaming so
it's very interesting because this is a
file format essentially so these are
files on in the object storage how like
where is the streaming coming from
um
but
in essence uh it all it all looks
exactly the same we can read the delta
lake table we can make transformations
and then we can even write to another
intellect table again in a streaming
mode and what happens is that
because now it's not just files but also
the metadata the reader and writer in
both cases it's almost the same they can
read for example let's talk about
rereader it can read the the commits
that are new since
the last time it read so and that's how
it can understand what are the new files
and like if you think about kafka topic
for example it's very similar the reader
knows the offset that it has read the
last time and then it cannot just read
all the new records since then and again
memorize what is the current offset
where it stopped and then in this way we
can have a streaming job that reads from
data table writes the data table or you
can mix it with other sources and
destinations
and in this particular example every 10
seconds it would
run another read create a micro batch
and write to the output
and that's a very powerful feature and
it's completely based on the object
storage we don't have any kind of
uh systems that are inherently streaming
uh and another important uh piece of uh
yeah delta x format is the the ability
to update and delete
so for example we can
show the merge command which comes from
the standard ansi sql and merge allows
you to do absurd update or insert or
delete also at the same time
and so let's let's imagine we have a
data lake table by a certain path we
create kind of a reference to it
then we have a data frame that is our
like new records that we want to insert
or update to our data lake table
and we can do it this way that we say
dot merge
and we specify what is the the primary
key so what we should use to identify
that these records are the same and then
update or these records don't exist yet
and we insert and then in this example
it's super trivial we just say
if it matches by the primary key we
update if it doesn't we insert but
actually it can be
very fine-grained so you can specify
what fields to update or not you can
also delete and yeah it's pretty rich
syntax
i just wanted to show the simple example
here
all right so this was the storage format
now
let's quickly look also into the
serving
layer so to say and how we can access
this data now when we already have it
so again what are the requirements we
want to have a fast scalable general
purpose query engine
so that we can query this big data
easily and quickly
uh it should support unc sql which
everybody
is supposed to know
and again it has to be able to connect
to various
data sources so that would be very
useful it should be open source and
regular improved that's kind of standard
requirement we want from all of them
and then
there is such framework which is called
trino or formerly was called presto sql
it is a highly parallel distributed
query engine
it provides ansi sql
it's very fast
and scalable
it has a connector to broad variety of
data sources including dental lake
which was added just this year and that
was very very
hoped for and expected that at some
point it would happen and finally this
happened
and it can be queried essentially by any
dashboarding visualization tool
and if you know impala hive oppressor
then you can think of trina as
essentially a successor of
all those frameworks
again
quickly about the architecture very
similar to spark
it's a one coordinator multiple workers
architecture and when the client makes a
request which is just a string come with
an sql statement the coordinator
triggers multiple workers
which then actually read the data
transform it
potentially multiple stages with all the
shuffles happening
and then they either return it back
directly by coordinator to the
client or save it somewhere where it can
be read afterwards
there is one aspect that i need to cover
so to be able to sort of glue
delta lake and trino we need a metadata
store
uh
examples
probably familiar to you hive metastore
or in aws it would be glue
and apache spark is also able to write
and read to data lakes uh format as well
as to other forms like parque for
example via metadata store so
when it is connected to a metadata store
and that you don't specify exact paths
but rather a table name
all right so now we have covered all of
the pieces that we need
and we know like what we want we know
the
characteristics of the perfect uh data
platform so let's let's look at
um what it could look like given of
course that we we use an object storage
from the cloud and some compute and
metadata services from the cloud
so let me walk you through this
piece of architecture
so first of all we have a legend that
dashed lines mean read and the
solid lines mean right
in the bottom you can see that
we have three layers or tiers so on the
left ingestion and transformation layer
in the middle storage and metadata layer
and then on the right serving layer
and then in the heart of this
architecture you can see the data lake
tables
and that's kind of our our storage that
glues everything together and provides
all those features that enable the whole
lake house concept
and then together with the object
storage and the metals metadata store
delta lag tables they they form uh the
storage and metadata layer
then in terms of ingestion we would use
spark which would then read from all the
different external systems
and
ingest the data into different data lake
tables
and on the serving side
first of all we would use the trino for
the fast sql
access
but also together with again apache
spark that can provide uh like more
custom use cases when you want for
example this data to be moved somewhere
else for some downstream
systems you can use it as well and
together they would form the servant
layer and you can see that
so data analysts and data scientists
they most of the time would use
trino or like sql uh sometimes data
scientists as well as data engineers
would also use of course kind of more
custom processing
and do machine learning
with spark
now let's look at a little bit different
angle on this more on the data flow
so
here i have again three layers but in
this case it's it's layers of actual
storage
uh and uh we usually would have a raw
layer or like the lending zone where the
raw data
has been ingested as it is then there is
an intermediate layer where it maybe
would be
a little bit cleaned and reached and
deduplicated
and then the fine sorry and then the
final
layer would have potentially already
aggregated data join data data which is
much more ready for actual analytics and
data science
so if we look at the role here here i
made a couple examples so let's imagine
one spark job reads data from some
external system
and then another streaming
spark job reads again from some other
external system and they both write to
two different data lake tables and
there is almost no distinction actually
because really bad job uh
is just
an uh
like it usually would write it maybe
once a day or one several hours where a
streaming job would write with much
less much higher frequency
but yeah this is only
quantitative difference in essence
because streaming job if you set the
interval to to maybe one hour it becomes
essentially a byte job that runs every
hour
and then you can see that for example in
this case in an intermediate layer uh we
can mix and match the batch and
streaming jobs and even if a delay table
in the row layer was created in a batch
mode then uh in the intermediate one you
can maybe read it either from with with
the batch job or streaming job there is
really
you can do whatever you want in the
sense
and then essentially the same in the in
the last final layer
uh and then we see that both trina and
the patch spark again can be connected
to any of these tables
yeah
so if we come back now to the
characteristics we talked about our
north star
we can now
look at them once again and given this
architecture we can see that they
essentially fulfilled
so
we now have structured semi-structured
unstructured data just because data lake
format and together with the object
storage they they support all of these
different types of data sql and
sql-based workflows are possible patch
and streaming
uh
no modes of ingestion and processing are
provided by combination of spark and
delta lake metadata scheme on right
schema evolution all of this is
enabled by the data lake format asic
guarantees updates and deletes again are
enabled by deadline format
all the different use cases analytics
reporting that the science machine
learning all is now possible it's based
completely on open source except of
course for the cloud provider
and the storage in compute
again
if you use the cloud they would be
decoupled and pretty easy to scale out
and the storage is is cheap
um yeah this is this is almost it i just
want to quickly go over a list of things
that i haven't covered so of course this
is a little bit simplified
uh picture of such a data platform
we talked briefly about metadata store
but there is much more to it how to
organize it how to
configure the namespaces and databases
in the meta store
we didn't talk about the object storage
how you would actually organize
uh the buckets and the the parts and
then the permissions to different object
storage locations
uh we haven't talked at all about
workflow management and scheduling so
probably you need a system like maybe
airflow to actually trigger the jobs and
to
retry them if they fail and so on
you need authorization most of the time
especially if you have data privacy laws
that require you to be compliant and
to give access to data only
if there is a business reason for that
again compliancy with data privacy laws
we haven't talked about data quality so
somehow you also need to
make sure that
the data you provide in the final layer
it is reliable and it it doesn't miss
big portions of the data for example
uh we haven't talked about the lineage
which means
um what is the the history of of the
final data set like where did the
different columns different records
records come from
uh we didn't talk about data
visualization so maybe
on top of trina you can
put tableau or microstrategy or some
other framework that would actually
visualize the data using that engine
um
we could also talk about disaster
recovery how we use the object storage
features and data lake format features
to also make sure that our data doesn't
get lost if something weird happens
yeah and there are other topics of
course so you can see it's a big list of
different aspects which all require a
lot of
thorough
thinking and design
but of course we couldn't talk about all
of them here
and yes that was it
thank you very much and yeah if you have
any questions please call
[Applause]
okay
you said that gina have multiple workers
architecture and spark is the same
architecture
but and
it's it means that
every system there can be multiple
workers that
where
multiple uh
reading operations come from
to our files in data data lake format
and
best files just in one
place so can delta lag be
distributed over
multiple
places over
multiple machines disks so
yeah so
yeah here we really just refer to this
and in fies
can you please tell us more about uh
consistency mechanisms
yeah so basically the object storage
itself provides us the
distribution in the sense that it's a
high level abstraction it's kind of
serverless you can call it but of course
behind it there is a
flexible or elastic set of computers and
hard drives that would store your
physical file so when we create a data
lake table in a bucket somewhere in an
object storage
when we put files in there
we really don't need to think about this
at all but yeah behind the scenes there
will be multiple machines
which how to scale and store as much
data as you want so you can have
files of i think in like in in aws one
file can be up to five terabytes and
then the number of files i don't even
remember if there is really a limit so
uh yeah scalability in this sense comes
from the object storage but also the the
way the metadata works
it helps to facilitate the the fact even
if you have thousands of files or even
more uh the the way it reads uh tries to
optimize it so that you need to to do
the least amount of work to actually
read those files and this works both the
same way for the trino connector and
spark connector so they they work
essentially in the same way that they
read this metadata and then only read
the files
um
what was it the second part about
consistency so
yeah
yeah it seems that uh the only way to
do this is just
to use a built-in mechanism of cloud
providers
well so the consistency that comes from
the acid acronym which is essentially
consistency in view of uh distributing
systems
okay yeah uh
so basically what you're saying is like
if it is a strong or uh eventual
consistency yeah so
so for example again aws s3 has
currently already strong consistency for
the read after write which means that
when you write a file immediately if you
list or get try to read this file
you get it so this is a relatively new
feature that i think was added year or
two ago
but
yeah the thing is i think that the
writer anyways would be
the place where this will be required to
check so basically the writer would be
outputting the files to the object
storage
and only as soon as
it can verify that they are completely
written and can be fetched would write
the commit so
do not make the reader experience
the fact that the files are
not
there yet so in case of these storage uh
like object storage systems of other
clouds that don't have strong
consistency and to be honest i'm not
entirely sure so with with the aws it
became
uh yeah covered by the strong
consistency of the object storage
recently thank you
in terms of security
it seems we have
a log of changes
and if you need to completely delete
some data
we just mark
it as deleted but it's still persistent
in log
does it have some resolution
yeah so just to maybe given a bit of a
context so if we if we run a delete
command what happens is that
the file where this record that we want
to delete it will not be deleted
immediately actually the writer will
create a new file without this record
write it and commit and the old file
will still keep the the record that we
want to delete and yeah if it is like a
compliance reason we kind of
we we didn't really fulfill it so in
this case we have to actually delete
that file and we cannot keep the history
and cannot really do the time travel
because otherwise yeah we contradict two
two different features they just
contradict each other so delhi lake has
a command to
remove all the previous history up to
certain time in the past that can be
used so it's called vacuum so you can
actually clean up
all the files from the past
and maybe you can have a trade-off if if
your
deadline for deleting the date is for
example 30 days and not immediate so you
can still have like 30 days of history
where you can time travel but then yes
you have to delete the history as well
yeah thank you very much for uh for a
great talk i
i had a question regarding this slide
with the with the architecture with like
uh with the layers uh of yes so i have
two questions the first question is do
do you employ any data warehousing
design like snowflake data vault data
and curve for your intermediate layer
and the second question is
if you don't trust the schema
from the external system so what i mean
by that is if the schema of the data
that comes in changes
um
change changes some schema
that then delta cannot
cannot support like the evolutions for
schema for example if the field was like
integer and b becomes string
uh
how do you deal with it in the role
layer because delta obviously cannot
support the schema evolution yeah
so for the first question yes you can do
and that's that's also the case uh
in my experience that you would do like
star schema or snowflake schema or any
other
um yeah approach for like data warehouse
data modeling um so this is essentially
a different dimension and there is no
the lake itself
doesn't like encourage or or contradict
it so you can do it or you cannot
um so like we did it we had fact tables
and dimension tables and then they would
be joined and as usually
and for the
problems with the source data
so most of the time you would just need
to
report that back to the external system
so because
uh otherwise a
um
so it really depends so if it is a
external system that you agreed on
certain schema and suddenly it starts
providing it in a different way so they
just broke the convention the contract
if it is a system that also supports
certain schema evolution
uh yeah here you can have issues so
delta lake also supports schema
evolution
at least it supports adding new columns
uh if the column type changes from one
to another that is uh yet not supported
but i think it's just it cannot be
supported
uh and yeah in in every such case
uh you would need to somehow resolve so
either
it's an incident and you go and try to
resolve it directly or
if there is sort of a standard uh
then you need either to support like
half of use cases so we actually had
such a situation when central messaging
bus it would be
more flexible than the data lake format
and like they were
subset of data sets that would be
supported and schema evolution would be
aligned uh a possible scheme evolution
and then subset of the the topics and
data sets that we would be not be able
to support if they change in a more
flexible way than data lake supports
yeah thank you very much
[Applause]